a thing and put for the question of uh
of the government paying for health care
and for that I remember when I was
president of the national Medical
Association the American Medical
Association was fighting Medicare uh as
president of the national Medical
Association I insisted that we must
support uh Medicare because so many
blacks and so many poor people could not
pay for medical care Medicare and uh at
that age and with the Medicare they
would be assured of a good training when
we met with President Kennedy in those
days we pointed out Grew From the
national Medical Association the rule
for the program 100 now